Liz Oh how did you feel out there for
Entertainment Tonight oh I feel wear
wigs tossing drinks being yeah I was a
moment it was bigger than that man it
was a spiritual catharsis for all of us
it was released we were feeling good as
hell and the whole crowd felt good as
hell hopefully the whole world is right
the tempo was right the truth did not
hurt all of my songs Missy Elliott
tonight what does it mean to make your
VMA debut on this stage the same time as
Missy Elliott's being honored whoa
that's a deep ask question because I was
like the year that she gets the Vanguard
Award I just want to be there I just
want to be a part of it somehow I always
told myself that and the fact that it
actually happened means that dreams do
come true when you truly can't manifest
your reality I mean and then to be
starring in a movie with JLo brunost a
year of Liz Oh 2019 is a star of listen
I'm not starting in the boop boop is JLo
but I'm in a movie with JLo JLo and
Constance were the stars and you know
I'm just a little planet in the galaxy
but it's honor tell me about this
looking what's in here oh so this is
Aquila now here's the seat I wasn't
allowed to have like a full bottle of
tequila so we had one shot I took the
whole shot on accident right before my
speech knows like so I was late so
whatever I said I don't remember about
your fashions for tonight
oh my god this is a custom Marc Jacobs
gown he's the UH he won the fashion
Vanguard Award so you know I had to
represent my boo and I got a diamond
earring on in a side ponytail from the
Beyonce baby hair feeling I just had a
DNA test and lizzo is 100% the hottest
thing at the VMAs sure thank you
[Laughter]
narrator unary she puts her lips to the
golden chalice she is drinking what oh
that is tequila period puh Wow
we're having fun with Liz Oh backstage
at the VMAs
[Applause]
[Music]